I was talking to Kevin Durant about how
I was doing this interview and he said
that he had a question okay and the
question that he wants me to ask you is
are you going to drop a snippet of you
all song on the radio
[Laughter]
show see I say why would K do that
because see I'm you know I'm a true you
already know you know this I'm a true
that was that was on the rap that was on
the low I was not you see KD you messed
up now now that you done that I just
want you to know you messed up the out
and that song was being considered to be
on Carter 6 and I said you have said
something it's not going
okay now that you ruined it no uh no I'm
not playing a snippet because I just
told the people how important this song
get the first is it actually was
supposed to go on uh the KY girl welcome
to KY gr album with me in two chains
that just came out
but I I I I you know I saved it I want
for something else yeah he kind of go
crazy on there so yeah well when I asked
about it him about it he said to ask you
so give me tell me about it what is he
like as as an artist in the studio uh I
wasn't in the studio with him he sent it
that's another thing these days totally
different yeah you know back then you
had to actually meet up with the person
you know go to the studio deal with
their Entourage and your entourage too
you know all that all that had to go and
so but now you know it's a text yeah you
text the song I text it back to going to
finish you know literally and he did and
um as far as his style to me KD is a a
you know he's um he's a what you call it
he's a a Jew you know like something of
of the past because he's a backpack
rapper I can imagine KD probably could
rap right you know I can imagine
probably could call a timeout in the
game and probably ask him to rap and he
probably got he got a verse for you fire
yeah you know me I need you know I'm so
perfectionist I need hold on hold on
hold on hold on you know
know hold I might tried to say something
about what what's going on and all that
you know KD probably just got bars yeah
and it sounds like it I love that you
know I was saying to him like you know
as he's been getting some into being an
anr some producing obviously some
actually using his voice I was saying to
him like you know Shaq's second phase of
his career was TV sha that we see but we
know him as that I think it'd be really
cool that whenever KD is no longer in
the basketball court if his second phase
of his career is music and we know him
for that I think would be really fire
for him because he does love it to your
point now you to to rap the way he does
you you have to put time in it that way
and also you could you could hear a you
can hear a kind of a innate you can kind
of hear a where it's just a him it's
just him in it you know what I mean
something like you know almost the way
he plays yeah you know that just almost
like it's I don't want to use the word
Lexa Desu but almost like it's just too
easy smooth yeah yeah you can hear that
in the you you can hear that I didn't I
didn't have to do too much thinking for
him how good that bar was yeah you know
about what they say about KD easy easy
money easy money yeah definitely yeah
absolutely